staying neutral in the face of conflict
many countries decided against taking
sides in the russia-ukraine war but what
does neutrality mean and can a nation
truly avoid siding with either this is
inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim joom many countries have
decided to avoid taking sides in
russia's invasion of ukraine 35 nations
abstained from voting on a u.n
resolution condemning the conflict and
russia's president demanded ukraine be
declared neutral as a condition to
ending the war but the concept of
neutrality is under question
the invasion led to finland and sweden
that had long been militarily neutral
applying to join the nato alliance
india is officially not aligned with
either russia or ukraine but it has
faced criticism for doubling its imports
of russian oil
even switzerland known worldwide for
neutrality is debating its meaning media
reports say the government vetoed german
and danish requests to supply swiss-made
armored vehicles to ukraine as that
would violate switzerland's neutrality
but the country followed much of the
west by imposing sanctions and freezing
russian assets in february
the swiss president said neutrality
doesn't mean being indifferent to
aggression
why did we take this decision
other democracies must be able to rely
on switzerland states that stand for
international law must be able to rely
on switzerland
and states that uphold human rights must
be able to rely on switzerland
the federal council examined the
question of neutrality under this light
playing into the hands of an aggressor
is not neutral
all right let's take a look at what
neutrality means it broadly means not
taking sides in armed conflict between
warring countries and abstaining from
providing military assistance
countries interpret neutrality
differently for example finland and
sweden are more relaxed about their
status and describe themselves as
non-aligned whereas neutral countries in
europe are bound by the policies of the
european union
most countries declare their neutrality
while some are permanently neutral by
either constitutional decree or as part
of a previous treaty
during hostilities a neutral state may
repeal change or modify its position
all right let's bring in our guests
joining us on the line from new delhi
happy mon jacob associate professor of
diplomacy at joaharla nehru university
and founder of the council for strategic
and defense research
in zurich mark farhat author and adjunct
professor of sociology at the university
of zurich
and in oslo glen diesen professor of
international relations at the
university of southeast norway a warm
welcome to you all and thanks so much
for joining us on the program today mark
let me start with you today um
there seems to be some confusion out
there when it comes to the concept of
neutrality so i want to take a step back
for a moment and ask you about the
difference between the law of neutrality
versus the politics of neutrality how
those two things differ
that's a tough one well i can speak from
a swiss perspective because switzerland
is obviously known as maybe the first or
still the only state made in the world
that has neutrality enshrined in its
very constitution and that goes back
actually a long time there was a battle
in 1516 in marina where the swiss you
know we're trying to overextend
themselves and were warriors still had
the vatican guard today if you remember
their mercenaries and after that kind of
bitter defeat that they had there
they came to the conclusion that that
neutrality would be a better option this
was only enshrined really after the
council of vienna 1815
council of paris and then later as you
probably know the convention denhag 1907
uh and so on but uh it is something that
comes naturally to switzerland because
it's a country kind of perched here in
the middle of europe between contesting
powers
you know taking sides is a costly affair
if you bet on the wrong horse or if
you're
caught in the sort of crosshairs of
these contending powers and that's also
why switzerland then became of course
the center in the world for diplomacy
and neutrality then is integrally linked
to the peace that we've had in
switzerland and prosperity
and other countries then look to
switzerland as a paradigm but today with
this new conflict of course this is all
in danger and questioned again but the
legacy of it is basically to keep out of
these conflicts to preserve one's own
stability and to act as a platform for
diplomacy and peaceful conflict
mediation
glenn was the concept of neutrality
interpreted differently in the past say
during the cold war era or during world
war ii was it interpreted differently in
the past than it is today
well um as my colleague suggested it is
interpreted in different ways
i guess during the cold war it was
mostly uh
it was uh very much defined as obviously
not being part of
either of the blocks in order to reduce
the tension from these blood politics
that's why we saw in europe during the
cold war we had this belt of neutral
states uh so finland sweden austria
switzerland which kind of created the
buffer zone
making germany the only frontline
so i think we linked it more to uh
membership in uh military alliances but
of course um neutrality also encompasses
not taking sides in any armed conflicts
such as providing weapons to one side
during a war
um but i think some of the ideas about
neutrality has has was obscured after
the cold war it's common to to argue now
that neutrality is only over the past
three months being began to collapse but
it began to collapse uh soon thereafter
after the cold war because
[Music]
well there was an absence of uh upon
european security architecture so we saw
that
nato began to take on the role of
representing europe so nato expansionism
essentially became the main force for
what we refer to as european integration
so neutrality effectively then meant to
be marginalized from the only security
architecture there was on the continent
so
the whole idea of naturality has changed
a lot during
the post-cold war era which is why we
also see that it's been collapsing over
the past 30 years
mark i saw you nodding along to some of
what glenn was saying there and it
looked like you might have wanted to
jump in so go ahead
well just a footnote but i think we all
agree but this is a debate in
switzerland right now because
definitionally neutrality meant
a non-military intervention and now the
question with sanctions is is that a
military intervention or not or does
that violate the law of neutrality which
is enshrined in the swiss constitution
the swiss constitution not explicit on
this the military intervention is is the
red line definitely and so delivering
weapons to a conflict zone has
traditionally been seen as as a you know
as something prohibited by the swiss
vice versa well mark let me follow up
with you on that point because you know
as you mentioned i mean switzerland
essentially is having its neutrality
tested somewhat publicly right now you
know there is this debate over swiss
neutrality it's been intensifying due to
the war in ukraine the fact that swiss
government signed up to the sanctions on
russia you know as you mentioned some
viewed that as a sign that switzerland
has abandoned its neutrality is this
debate in switzerland going to grow are
we going to see more lawmakers bringing
it up uh talking about it is how much is
the public involved in this debate right
now
well that's a very good point because
all these decisions were made top down
without recourse to the public and
switzerland is the only direct democracy
in the world it says in the swiss
constitution the people are the
sovereign so at the end if there's a
referendum they can overturn any
decision made by the federal council but
the federal council unilaterally decided
to in its essence violate or soften if
you want the neutrality of switzerland
um
i would just add a footnote too to the
cold war it's not true that switzerland
was entirely neutral even before the
during the cold war it always was
deciding you know with with the us in a
sense and uh also you remember 1991 uh
switzerland participated in the uh
sanctions against iraq so people forget
that maybe a little bit so it's there's
a precedent there there has been as and
said by my colleague certainly after the
cold war certainly a softening of this
whole thing and switzerland has a
partnership with peace with nato so even
though it's not a member of nato de
facto kind of is so you know all the eu
is another example switzerland decided
that people decided to vote against
membership in the eu but the federal
council opened all kinds of doors to the
eu that de facto switzerland became a
member of the eu and the same now with
these sanctions here now the court
you're right there is probably if this
continues and if the federal council
today or tomorrow decides to deliver you
know munitions to germany and then to
the ukraine denmark then i think there
will be a national referendum or
initiative now how that will turn out is
another question because there are some
people that are for and against but i
think that we will come to that
eventually because neutrality is
something sacred to a lot of swiss maybe
not to all maybe not even to a majority
but to a lot this was one of the
bedrocks of the country happy month let
me ask you india is not officially
aligned with either russia or ukraine i
want to look for a moment at the
difference between neutrality and
non-alignment how is one different from
the other
right um thank you mama for asking that
question i think this is uh often
misunderstood
by a lot of people
globally as to what is india's stance
when it comes to some of these issues as
you know of historically ever since the
attained it depends in 1947 uh it has
claimed uh itself to be a non-aligned
power um
internationally it has not aligned
itself with
either the soviet bloc or the u.s
network during the cold war years uh
except when of course um india was india
felt an acute uh sense of insecurity say
for example during the 1971 war between
india and pakistan over bangladesh at
that point of time india signed a piece
of treaty and french friendship with
the united uh the ussr but for most part
of it india has claimed that it is a
non-aligned country now you ask me the
difference between uh non-alignment and
neutrality in the way we see in india
neutrality means that you don't take a
position on any external um warranties
issue um you know either either the two
blocks are fighting or two countries are
fighting uh you have no opinion on that
you you don't take a decision on that
you don't act on uh act on it whereas
non-alignment would mean that in general
you are not aligned to a country is not
aligned to either of the two blocks um
but it will continue to have an opinion
um on what is happening it will continue
to take a position or take an action
which is in its own national interest uh
which means you have not neutered the
country of its opinion what you have
done basically is that in general we are
not aligned to any two or any of the two
blocks or any of the any of the blocks
out there
but we will uh take a decision on a
particular issue based on the merits of
uh the uh uh circumstances
i think that is a very significant
distinction to understand because india
is not a neutral power india as you know
during um you know during the period of
time
and various other prime ministers have
been pretty active on the global scene
talking about um say for example
decolonization or pathway um or or the
or the evil effects of the cold war
exercise which was an active power at
the same time it was a non-aligned power
so it was not a neutral power it always
had its opinion
it put forward
solutions it mediated in the korean war
in the korean war for example so it was
an active power not a neutral power
right it's a non-aligned active power
not a new neutral power
happy one let me also ask you i mean
india has come under a lot of pressure
by countries like the us and other
western countries to try to change its
stance uh when it comes to russia and
ukraine do you think that there's any
scenario by which india would actually
take a stance against russia's invasion
of ukraine
i think
the thinking in delhi was that when the
war began
uh earlier this year uh by the russians
in ukraine uh we imagined that this was
going to be a quick walk i think much of
the international community believed
that to be the case um like for example
the uh
like like it happened in 2014 so that
assumption has
uh you know turned out to be completely
erroneous so if this war persists for a
very long time if this is going to lead
to a humanitarian tragedy in ukraine i
believe you are probably going to look
at a lot more pressure on india both
internally and externally to change its
opinion on what's going on let me let me
also sort of caveat uh you know my
argument by saying that it has not
really
supported the russian war um say for
example in 2014 uh india has said that
both sides have legitimate interest um
india has not made that made that
argument in 2022 if you look at the
india's explanations of what at the
united nations security council and the
united nations general assembly india
has made the argument that it is
important to um honor international law
so what may be a safeguarding it is
important external address is not a good
idea he has made all those correct
argumentation in its explanation and yet
india refused to um let's say what
against the ratio of condom russia so it
so by not condemning russia one could
make the argument that india is subtly
pro-russia right now it is certainly
pro-russia not because it likes what
russia is doing but because of the uh
geopolitical environment
which is you know you're looking at a
very difficult uh geopolitical
environment where china is actually um
um you know putting pressure on india so
i think to answer your question very
quickly mohammed i think um if this war
persists and if this war becomes
blurrier there will be lots more
pressure on india internally and
externally i think there will be some
rethinking uh glenn going forward will
the countries that maintain their
neutrality still play an important
diplomatic role in finding political
solutions to conflict or do you think
that their influence will wane
well uh i think their influence will
begin to decline because there's hardly
any more neutral countries
left in europe i think
with if now that sweden and finland
especially has uh argued that they will
join
nato i think
you will see less and less of this and
they will be seen to be participants of
the conflict and by taking sides there's
also less of a diplomatic role they can
have which is why we've seen more of the
diplomatic role have having been shifted
towards uh turkey now turkey obviously
is a nato member but still you see them
having more of an independent foreign
policy and openly stating for example
they're not going to join in on all of
these sanctions so i i think that the
the decline of neutrality will
definitely have an impact on on
on
on the diplomacy and the ability to
promote peace it also has to be said
that i think uh
um
i i think that uh
the decline in the child is also not
just promote preventing uh diplomacy but
it's also provoking
uh conflicts and war and and i think
finland might regret this uh this
decision because keep in mind what what
happened to ukraine i think it's often a
common narrative now that uh if ukraine
had been in nato then there wouldn't
have been a war but i think in reality
it was that the u.s and nato efforts to
end the ukrainian neutrality that
eventually provoked russia because if we
see what the ukrainian experience was
from its independence under president
kuchma the whole idea was that they
should never join nato without russia if
they join with russia then it would be
fine but without russia there would be a
front line against russia that would
undermine the neutrality so they tried
to be neutral uh until the color
revolution in 2004 when this was the
western backbone which was linked to
nato expansion uh and then relations
then again deteriorated until 2010 when
yanukovych was selected and ukraine
again pushed the idea that it was a
neutral state then things got uh
calm again and then we saw the toppling
of yanukovych in 2014 with western
support and this is what then again
unraveled uh the conflict as this was
seen to be another effort by nato to to
rob ukraine of its neutrality and even
the 2015 minsk agreement that was seen
by russia to a large extent as a way of
cementing
ukraine's neutrality uh but
unfortunately it never went anywhere and
so i i think that uh
definitely the decline of neutrality or
collapse of neutrality in europe will
continue to make diplomacy more and more
difficult and create more
areas of conflict
mark um you know following up on on what
glenn was saying there um let me ask you
about perceptions of neutrality around
the world right now at a moment like
this does it seem to you that more
people are are viewing the concept of
neutrality negatively
well yes i mean i think there was in in
different cases now in this ukraine
russia war which is somewhat a sibling
war right if you think about it uh
between brothers almost uh and the media
has of course stoked these this haters
russia phobia everywhere tennis players
being banned what have you which is very
uncanny and uh regrettable really um
i i do think neutrality has gone out of
vogue right which is very unfortunate
especially for a country like
switzerland and that's why it's
especially you know galling to see
switzerland you know jump into this so
so so so uh precipitously and i would
say there's a broader crisis here
frankly speaking um you know neutrality
is not something that's even foreign to
the united states if you think about the
founding fathers they were saying we
don't want to go abroad to search for
monsters to destroy and then over time
america got involved and embroiled in
more and more wars
recently we know as well and it became
de facto and empire so to speak and
someone like you know john merzheimer
the famous realist warned against that
as a really saying we shouldn't go you
know abroad and become an empire
and we have as i'm a united
as well
and switzerland now is unfortunately
also jumping on this bandwagon to a
degree but i would say both cases in the
united states and in switzerland and
other cases these decisions were made i
repeat top down it wasn't really a
democratic process there never was
really uh you know a vote on whether we
should go into iraq or into libya into
other countries now ukraine etc a lot of
these decisions were taken top down
especially in switzerland and i think
there will be a populist sort of
resentment at some point because there's
a huge economic crisis going we should
maybe talk about that too because all
these countries are going to probably
suffer more from the sanctions than
russia is and that's a very important
point to underscore too i think that
breaking this neutrality is yes it's
endangering global peace because
diplomacy is no longer on the table and
a country like switzerland find it
difficult to act as a diplomat but also
economically i think the consequences
are very severe and not necessarily
positive for anyone ukrainian russian
european american civilians so i think
that's important
happy month at a time when dialogue and
diplomacy uh oftentimes aren't achieving
their aims uh when it comes to trying to
find political solutions to conflicts
different parts of the world are
institutions like the u.n in decline
i think there is uh absolutely no doubt
about the fact that the united nations
is on a terminal decline we hardly hear
of
the united nations being able to do
anything um anywhere around the world
and it's such a pity
in any case
one organization that is supposed to
safeguard peace and
security of the international system
which is the united nations security
council has become so defense uh in any
case uh at this point of time russia is
only um uh it has always become the u.n
security council so um i think this
argument that a lot of us who have been
making from the global south um
including india that the global um
international organizations need a
fundamental restructuring um
today's uh united nations security
council or global various other global
institutions do not represent the
reality of the contemporary
international system these were set up
at the at the at the end of the second
world war uh to shoot the uh victors and
their uh geopolitical uh aids uh they
hold absolutely nobody today so it's
unfortunate that we don't have um any
any any credible systems or structures
in place in order to uh mediate during
crisis or to bring about peace and
security so i think um
you know notwithstanding what happens um
at the end of this war in ukraine or or
in russia there is a serious rethinking
that is required by the international
community on um what kind of structural
systems are required
for keeping peace um going forward i
think this is something that has been
demanded by the uh by the powers of the
global south
glenn there are many countries in europe
that may be rethinking their neutrality
right now because of the war in ukraine
but what about other countries around
the world are are a lot of other
countries around the world struggling
with this as well right now
well
from my perspective at least the way i
see it i think it's mainly a european
problem uh because you know we spoke
about india but again it's um it's a
they're trying to adapt to a new reality
again when you have countries like india
they see the rise of china they might be
concern
and therefore seeking closer
partnerships with united states japan
and other
countries in the region on the other
hand you also see that the underlying
countries like india is very
apprehensive about not being seen to
join an alliance that targets
china so you therefore see a very
cautious language that is
they want to be
these formations to be pro-asian and not
anti-chinese for example
so so effectively not be seen as going
against the chinese so
so for this reason i don't think
neutrality in asia for example is
falling apart
in the form of a
development of an asian nato so i think
again a lot of this goes back to the
whole
the whole what's very unique about
europe which is uh
that after the cold war we had this uh
move first that we were gonna have an uh
security architecture which wasn't
linked to this competing uh
cold war security military blocks and
and again i think
people people don't always appreciate
what exactly happened because if we saw
in 1909 at the osce meeting now the osce
was supposed to be like an inclusive
security institutions which uh which
would
reduce the role of this military
alliances uh we saw that the russians
they committed themselves for example to
withdrawing their peacekeepers from both
moldova and georgia however when they
saw that the uoc would not be some
inclusive uh
impartial security alliance uh because
of nato expansionism they saw nato
effectively replacing them this they
came to the conclusion they couldn't
pull out because either they have their
troops there or they will join nato so
having troops in these countries became
a tool for kind of imposing the
challenge on them and this is uh this
has been kind of the experience over the
years in
in europe all right well we are out of
time so we're going to have to leave the
discussion there thanks so much to all
of our guests mark farhat happy mon
jacob and glenn diesen
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside storage for
me mohammed jim joham and the whole team
here bye for now
[Music]
you